ma réaction c'est que malheureusement
ces chiffres confirment qu emmanuel
macron a totalement perdu la maîtrise
de la politique migratoire et que
jamais les flux migratoires à
destination de notre pays n'ont été
aussi important si on rentre dans le
détail
on a délivrés l'année dernière
pratiquement 270 mille titres de séjour
ont frôlé le record de 2019
ça veut dire que il ya plus que jamais
une très forte pression migratoire qui
s'exerce sur la france on enregistré
plus de cent mille demandeurs d'asile
donc le petit répit qui avaient été
constatés en 2020 à cause de la crise
sanitaire qui avait entraîné la
fermeture des frontières extérieures qui
avait entraîné la fermeture de nos
consulats pendant plusieurs semaines et
la fermeture des préfectures ce petit
répit les derrière nous on a retrouvé
une pression migratoire record sur la
france
[Musique]
avec macron ce sont des mots ce sont des
belles paroles ce sont des formules
creuses ou des formules valises par
exemple il a l'habitude de dire qu'il
faut réformer schengen qu'il faut faire
un schengen 2 tout ça c'est des mots
tout ça c'est des mots la vérité c'est
que il faut faire ce que propose valérie
pécresse modifier la constitution
mettre en place une politique de quotas
réformer profondément les procédures
d'asile faire en sorte que l'asile que
les demandes d'asile soient déposées et
instruite alors que les ressortissants
étrangers ne sont pas encore entrés sur
le territoire français il faut également
réserver les prestations sociales non
contributives à des étrangers ayant une
certaine durée de résidence et enfin il
faut que la nationalité française soit
réservé à des personnes assimilées qui
maîtrise parfaitement la langue
française quand une bonne connaissance
de notre histoire et de notre culture et
qui respecte les valeurs de la
république voilà ce que emmanuel macron
ne fait pas et voilà ce que propose
valérie pécresse
[Musique]
dans les 100 premiers jours de son
mandat
valérie pécresse initiera une révision
constitutionnelle
sur l'immigration son projet est prêt
elle l'a présenté pendant la primaire
c'est donc un projet de loi
constitutionnelle sur l'immigration qui
permet de mettre en oeuvre une politique
de quotas si on ne modifie pas la
constitution on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
mettre en oeuvre pour la france une
politique de quotas et la révision
constitutionnelle que valérie pécresse
propose permettra de surcroît de mettre
en échec la jurisprudence européenne
qui actuellement est une jurisprudence
qui est contraire aux intérêts de la
france en matière de maîtrise de la
migration et notamment en matière de
maîtrise du regroupement familial
pour ça il faut présenter un texte
devant les deux assemblées le faire voté
dans des termes identiques par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat ce
sera à l'ordre du jour des 100 premiers
jours et ensuite le soumettre au
référendum à partir sans doute du mois
de septembre pour son adoption par
l'ensemble des français
[Musique]
là où l'europe peut nous aider comme
elle à aider la grèce c'est à organiser
à la frontière une procédure d'examen
sérieux et approfondi des demandes
présentées par des ressortissants
étrangers qui veulent s'installer dans
un pays de l'union européenne et en
organisant cela à la frontière on se
donne les moyens lorsque l'étranger ne
remplit pas les conditions pour être
admis au séjour dans un pays de l'union
européenne on se donne les moyens de le
reconduire à la frontière dans son pays
ou dans le pays
d'où il vient c'est à la frontière
extérieure que se joue
l'essentiel de la bataille pour le
contrôle des flux migratoires à
destination de l'europe
il ya des formes de migration
dont la france peut avoir besoin je
prendrai deux exemples
il peut être intéressant pour la france
de continuer à accueillir des étudiants
étrangers
parce qu'ils peuvent à l'issue de leurs
études être en partant dans leur pays
d'origine ils peuvent être les
ambassadeurs de la culture française de
notre stratégie économique etc mais
encore faut-il évidemment que ces
étudiants qui viennent en france cet été
sélectionnés sérieusement et qu'on ait
vérifié qu'ils sont en capacité de
suivre des études supérieures
dans notre pays et puis on sait que le
fonctionnement de certains secteurs de
l'économie française peut nécessiter le
recours à une main d'oeuvre immigrés
bien dans ce cas là il faut l'organiser
et s'assurer que les migrants
économiques dont il s'agit sont
parfaitement adaptés aux métiers qui en
france souffre de difficultés de
recrutement